les réfugiés si je puis dire en liberté
à la frontière nous rentrons à
l'intérieur du de la thaïlande à environ
40 km de la frontière et nous sommes
dans un des camps de réfugiés où là nous
ne peut pas sortir du tout sac et aux
sacs et osseux quand il avait visité
madame carter et dans ce camp la plupart
des réfugiés sont d'origine khmers
rouges on les reconnaît à leur vareuse
et leur pantalon noir et vous allez
découvrir à travers ce reportage de
jacques à bouchard et de patrice du
tertre
comment un certain nombre de ces mer
rouge ont décidé de revenir au cambodge
pour aller combattre contre les
vietnamiens
jour j pour les rapatriements vers le
cambodge camp de saké au les candidats
au départ s'entassent à l'entrée du camp
et les soldats thaïlandais interviennent
avec une certaine rudesse pour éviter la
bousculade
officiellement tous les partants sont
volontaires ils ont confirmé aux
représentants des nations unies leur
désir de regagner les zones du cambodge
contrôlé par les khmers rouges
en réalité on a parlé d'un climat de
terreur imposé par les partisans de
polpot qui sont environ 8000 sur les
vingt-cinq mille réfugiés de saclay il
aurait même constituer une milice
chargée de mettre au pas les
récalcitrants au besoin par la manière
forte
le résultat est donc sans surprise dès
le début des opérations de rapatriement
les autres bus chargés du transport
jusqu'à la frontière se remplissent
rapidement l'objectif des chefs khmers
rouges est clair chaque cambodgien
rentrant pays devra renforcer la
résistance anti vietnamiennes après
l'effondrement de l'automne dernier
pourquoi vous le dire lui demander
pourquoi un rayon va combattre
volontaire ces retours massifs mais
renfermé rouge ça veut dire une reprise
intensive de la guerre conseille
évidemment en ce qui concerne les
célibataires oui il y a deux dans
beaucoup de gens de jeunes célibataires
garçons et 6 e pour votre rigueur les
autres je pense feront la rivière
surtout les mères de famille
elles resteront ils feront la rivière
les conditions de vie dans la zone mais
rouges au cambodge sont toujours aussi
dur difficile
sur quoi qu'elles sont très très austère
à l'entrée de la zone mer rouge il n'y a
pas la moindre effusion entre les
nouveaux arrivants et les hommes et les
femmes venus à leur rencontre en silence
on se hâte sur la piste pour rejoindre
les points de rassemblement fixé à 1 2
ou 3 jours de marche seule attaque
vietnamienne du 23 juin a interrompu le
reflux khmer rouge vers le cambodge à ce
moment là près de dix mille réfugiés de
saké au était déjà revenue au pays
et